- As light goes into your eye,
it first goes through your cornea,
the protective outer surface of the eye.
And then it hits your iris
which is the colored part of your eye.
The lens focuses the image
to the back of the retina
and then the retina tissue is where
the photoreceptor layers are
to detect the light impulses
and send them through the
optic nerve back to the brain.
(clicking)
Our eyes are unique and different
and everybody has a unique iris coloration
like a fingerprint on their eye.
And so our perception is unique.
Our eyes allow us to see
the good in the world.
- Turns out that recognizing things
is a really tough computational problem
and it costs a lot of neurons to do it.
So, do we see goodness?
When we're judging goodness
I think typically that's
a beauty judgment.
Spanish philosopher, George Santayana,
defined beauty as the pleasure
we attribute to the object.
These individuals differences
and what we find beautiful
are a very powerful and
common feature of our lives.
And this can apply in quite abstract ways.
And it's not just literally
what the motion is
but what it signifies.
- Okay, come forward.
Squint the eyes a little bit.
Good.
The most beautiful thing
that you see in a person
is the beauty in their eyes.
You can see their past, their presence
and where they are right at this moment
through the eyes.
(clicking)
So I did the first two
years of my modeling career
you know, totally in a blur
because I wasn't seeing well.
And when I got my contacts and glasses
I mean the whole world just opened up.
It was just like amazing
like this is the world.
This is what I've been missing.
- Eyes are critical in
order to see the world
and perceive the good in the world.
And so our perception is unique
and allows us to be beautiful in our way
as well as experience the beautiful colors
in the world around us.
- When you see good deeds
you just have that compassion
feeling in your eyes
and there's a warmth and a
feeling that overtakes you.
It's great.